space it's where things happen time it's
when things happen you can measure where
things are and when things take place
but in modern physics we realize when
and where are actually part of the same
question because when it comes to
understanding the universe we need to
replace three-dimensional space plus
time with a single concept
four-dimensional space-time will explore
and explain space-time in this series of
animations animations yeah well we're
not very animated are we sure we are
look I can go from here to here oh how
do you get from here to there how fast
did you go did you run walk did you even
go a straight line ah to answer that
you'll need to make our cartoon physics
look more like physics physics you'll
need more panels more panels please okay
in each panel Andrews in a slightly
different so I can see each one records
where Andrew is at a different time
that's great but it would be easier to
see what's going on if we could cut out
all the hundreds of panels and stack
them up like a flipbook right now let's
flip through the book so that we can see
one panel after another getting through
24 in every single see I told you it was
an animation now you can see me walking
along drawing all those panels and
putting them into a flip book it's just
one way of recording the wake I'm moving
its how animation or even movies work as
it turns out at my walking speed it
takes two seconds to get past each fence
post and they're spaced four meters
apart so we can calculate my velocity
how fast I'm moving through space this
two meters per second but I could have
worked it out from the panel's without
flipping through them from the edge of
the flip book you can see all of the
copies of the fence posts and all of the
copies of Andrew and he's in a slightly
different place
each one now we can predict everything
that will happen to Andrew when we flip
through 24 pages every second including
his speed of motion just by looking no
need to flip through at all the edge of
this flip book is known as a spacetime
diagram of Andrews journey through you
guessed it space and time we call the
line that represents Andrews journey his
world line if my jug instead of walking
I might be able to get past a fence post
every second he's not very athletic
anyway when we look at this new flip
book from the edge we can do the same
analysis as before the world line for
Andrew jogging is more tilted over than
the world line for Andrew walking we can
tell he's going twice as fast as before
without flipping the panel's
but here's the clever bit in physics
it's always good to view things from
other perspectives
after all the laws of physics should be
the same for everyone or no one will
obey them
so let's rethink our cartoon and have
the camera follow Andrew jogging along
as the fence post approach and pass
behind him still viewing it as a flip
book of panels we don't need to redraw
anything we simply move all of the
cutout frames slightly until Andrews
tilted world line becomes completely
vertical to see why let's flip it yes
now I'm stationary just jogging on the
spot in the center of the panel on the
edge of the flip book my world line was
going straight upwards the fence posts
are coming past me it's now their world
lines that are tilted this rearrangement
of the panel's is known as a Galilean
transformation and it lets us analyze
physics from someone else's perspective
in this case mine after all it's always
good to see things from other points of
view especially when the viewers are
moving at different speeds
so long as the speeds aren't to die if
you're a cosmic ray moving at the speed
of light our flipbook of your point of
view falls apart to stop that from
happening
we'll have to glue panels together
instead of a stack of separate panels
we'll need a solid block of space-time
which we'll come to in the next
animation
you